i want to go back to the early dungeon
family days
there's a couple of people who who uh a
lot of people don't know or associate
with dungeon family
and i want to kind of get your guys some
some context and some takes on on being
around because i heard usher was a part
of the dungeon family or at least around
y'all
super early um and the same thing with
future obviously
future's got a tattooed on his arm um
but but can you guys kind of
talk about like like being around there
like i sure obviously was a kid
um from what i i think i talked to big
boy about it but
you know just the important historical
context of
what's come from your guys's tree we
could throw usher in that we could throw
the future in that what was it like
being around those guys before we all
obviously you know knew who they were
hey look at that it was family man you
know what i'm saying there wasn't really
nothing exciting about being around none
of who was excited because we loved each
other you know what i'm saying nobody
had really accomplished nothing great at
that particular time so
you know what i'm saying the magic was
just just being around people that you
love people that support you and people
that you support
you know what i'm saying and they were
younger than us so they're like little
brothers they used to watch us
you know what i'm saying they used to
come to the studio i can remember seeing
you know we just called future me
here back in the day me i can remember
the first time he came to the studio
you know rico was like yeah that's my
little cousin you know what i'm saying i
met he was real cool real
real quiet guy you know saw spoken word
with it
loud he liked to learn he had to sit
around and really people out of
everything
everything was working and i can
remember popping in back in the day like
dungeon was was always just open door
policy for all of us
so i mean you can go over to the dungeon
man at three in the morning
you know 4 30 in the morning you know
what i'm saying somebody gonna be up
you know and it's gonna be somebody
kicking we
talk to kick it for a few minutes if you
want to go home you can do that you want
to stay you can stay
you know what i'm saying i could
remember coming in and seeing future
just working
in the studio just right i'm like who is
that like man that's me here
damn you know he about working you know
he put it in you know i could really
just see
his energy his his passion yeah
and it showed and it's still showing you
know what i'm saying
he wanted he wasn't the best in the game
right now you know what i'm saying
period
hands down can't nobody argue with that
you know what i mean and um it's lovely
to know
you know we saw him grow and the good
thing about it when we tell
this day is still the love and respect
though you know what i'm saying because
you know he a real gentleman he really
got you know real family members
you know saying that's how we roll but
yeah man um usher
i don't remember seeing him rhino but i
do remember seeing he wrote something on
that uh
hot water heater he wrote questions and
i was trying to figure out
what who was also what was that you know
i never knew what that meant then
i remember meeting him he was a little
kid no he was a kid yeah from what i
heard yeah
yeah he was a little he was a child just
like uh oh yeah who else came out from
one of the other day you didn't know
about you ain't saying
about that's uh mister bobby valentino
okay yeah they used to come over there
all the time remember they were little
kids
you know man coming over there you know
what i'm saying sucking up gang
you know i was saying getting tracks you
know saying learning learning the ropes
learning how to move
you know i mean and bobby held on to it
you know i was closer to him because i
knew
me and cujo and gil uh graduated from
high school with his sister
his older sister so that's family that's
little marcel to the end you know what i
mean so
you know we all family we all brothers
we all love each other we all support
each other man that's just how it is
right here around the dungeon family man